eh bien vous la reconnaissez c'est la
nouvelle renault la renault 4 la 4l
c'est une petite révolution 1961 l'idée
du président de la marque crée la
voiture blue jeans à la fois polyvalente
résistante populaire est exportable dans
le monde entier
la 4l c'est aussi de l'innovation le
large hayon à l'arrière la première
traction avant chez renault une faible
consommation en carburant et une bonne
tenue de route la première dans un
patient surprenante car en fait c'est la
suspension remarquable de la voiture et
absorbe absolument qualité de la route
ou à 150 mille anciens francs pour
s'offrir une 4l l'équivalent de 5000
euros aujourd'hui
la voiture se vend vite et en quantité
en 1966 cinq ans après sa sortie
lusine de billancourt fait le
millionième véhicule trépied l'événement
a été salué comme il convenait par les
ouvriers et la voiture vedette a fait
une sortie fracassante
la renault 4 s'impose dans les villes
dans les champs les gendarmes l'adoptent
les facteurs aussi et même les globe
trotteurs en 1973 ces deux jeunes hommes
ont bricolé leur 4l pour aller de nice à
abidjan vous allez entreprendre voyage
assez extraordinaire de communes km ça
représente aller retour ça représente
peu près 18 mille et quelques la 4l un
marqueur générationnel aussi présent à
la télé dans la preuve par quatre une
émission des années 70 de michel drucker
bayonne et saint jean de luz
s'affrontent dans une épreuve cocasse
faire rentrer un maximum de personnes de
son équipe dans la toute petite voiture
la fera pas rentrer comme ça non vous
avez peut-être entrer la moitié du corps
mais là l'autre moitié va rester à
l'extérieur ce qui serait dommage tout
de même
des générations se sont amusés dans ces
quatre ailes mais en 1992 fin de la
récré la 4l ne sera plus commercialisée
à la fin du mois de décembre en europe
la 4l est victime du progrès la faute à
l'obligation pour les voitures neuves
d'être équipé de pots catalytiques à
partir de 1993 la 4l reste malgré tout
un grand succès de l'industrie
automobile française avec 8 millions de
véhicules fabriqués en 31 ans
c'est aujourd'hui un objet de collection
[Musique]